also jetzt kommt natürlich hier wieder
die naturschützer an um einen so voll
scheiße
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen deshalb wasteland folge
meine stimme hat sich dort
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen kaka an also
hört sich natürlich sonst auch immer
aber heute ist es immens kacke denn ich
bin gerade aufgestanden
ganz einfach kein also ich bin gerade
aufgestanden meine stimme ist doch ein
wenig schlecht also noch nicht so ganz
fit fürs aufnehmen und ich muss auch
gleich weg deswegen müssen wir wieder
bei allen grund also ich habe mir die
challenges ein bisschen anders
angeordnet und zwar haben wir schon
geschafft kommission den retter monster
fall nun endlich annehmen zu verlangen
und 1 geschafft stammelte geschafft
übrigens danke an die ganzen person die
mir das in die kommentare geschrieben
haben und zwar mache ich mir meinte
nämlich wir sollen die monster falle nur
zwei hoch machen weil dort sonst ganz
viele ende märz reinkommen die klauen
die ganze blöcke und natürlich nicht so
schön
also danke an euch an dem fall ist echt
hammer dass er mir da immer sachen in
die kommentare schreibt tipps und so
weiter finde ich sehr geil und sehr nett
von euch muss ich muss man auch einfach
mal so sagen und ich würde sagen dass
wir das ganze dann zwei hoch bauen ich
werde erst mal ganz kurz hoch gehen habe
ich überhaupt ich brauche unbedingt mehr
sand oder mirko pistolen keine ahnung wo
wir noch was also monster falle müssen
wir noch fertig machen wir haben schon
einen sicheren weg punkt haben wir schon
gebaut dann brauchen wir noch eine kraft
in fackel recht verlassen aufgabe ihr
okay habe auf jeden fall auch schon ein
haus haben wir schon wir sollen wolle
machen das haben wir auch schon gemacht
also wenn man sogar schon ein bett finde
erde von zwei von zwei zusätzlichen
orten habe ich beide auch schon gefunden
also es war die usa sondern diese andere
orte da ganz oben auf dem turm war
melonen vom pilz farben und eine
kuhherde haben wir auch schon eine coole
heimischen coo werde
moment da muss ich mal gucken
wirklich schon eine kuhherde haben wir
schon überhaupt nicht gefunden
ich weiß es gerade gar nicht dann halt
nicht irgendwo eine kuh ich weiß ich
weiß gar nicht naja wenn schon ist die
weg oder so in einer dsv noch finden so
das was wir jetzt noch machen müssen ist
ein kaktus farm eine zuckerrohr farm
mehr lava finden und einen stonebridge
kräften so das heißt ich würde sagen wir
beschäftigen uns erst mal mit der
monster verlieren noch ein wenig und
zwar machen wir die ganze jetzt zwei
hoch oder wie hoch ist denn jetzt
eigentlich jetzt ist er drei hoch oder
noch höher die dies vier hoch kommt die
kann man auch direkt allerdings machen
zwei hoch machen
das ist dann viel besser ich werde
wahrscheinlich eh nicht so film und
nutzen sondern nur machen damit hier die
aufgabe erfüllt ist aber wenn er keine
ändern ernst und bonn ist natürlich dann
auch wieder ganz gut ich habe mich auch
gerade
gerade haben wir schon die crew davoser
mirko herkriegen also ich hab noch
nirgendwo jetzt irgendwo eine kuh
gesehen kann einfach mal ein bisschen
rumlaufen gucken ob ich schon eigene kuh
gefunden habe aber sonst habe ich
eigentlich gerade keine ahnung naja
übrigens habe ich gerade hier das video
hochgeladen ja wie ich aufnehmen haben
wahrscheinlich einige von euch gesehen
einige vielleicht auch nicht weil es ein
wenig interessiert ist mir auch egal
jedenfalls möchte ich mich dafür
entschuldigen dass das video dass ich
das in zwei parts hochladen musste und
zwar musste ich das denn ich habe mir
die testversion von bundy cam für das
aufnehmen von meinem bildschirm und so
runtergeladen und ich wusste ich dass
man damit nur zehn minuten aufnehmen
kann und nachher wollte ich das dann so
einfach in premiere zusammenschneiden
so wie ich das eigentlich immer machen
und dort gegen auch allerdings war meine
stimme tut
ich weiß nicht woran das lag aber die
wahrheit total langsam und ich komme mir
gar nicht erklären woran das lag
jedenfalls habe ich dann versucht
schneller zu machen und so weit ging
halt alles nicht und naja wegen einfach
in zwei parts ist einfach beide parts
angucken und office bescheid
übrigens was ich mal fragen wollte mit
mir dazu einfällt warum ihr eigentlich
meine videos guckt das ist eine frage
die ich dann schon mal gestellt
aber da frage ich mich echt immer wieder
und zwar habe ich das letzte ist schon
mal bei facebook gefragt ich dann aber
relativ schnell wieder gelöscht weil ich
anders beantworten haben wollte
die ich jetzt ein bisschen vortragen
kann wenn ihr bei facebook gefällt mit
rückseite immer auf dem neuesten stand
ganz einfach und zwar meinen da einige
leute also der hauptteil meint wirklich
aber du bist eigentlich so einer wie
jeder andere auch nur bei dir ist das
witzige bei anderen let's play an wenn
die einfach nur rumstehen
oder halt irgendwie so langweilige
sachen machen wie zum beispiel stein
farm oder zum monster falle bauen dann
ist das total langweilig dann schaltet
man direkt aus bei dir ist es irgendwie
trotzdem ganz interessant und da stehen
ihm überhaupt nicht ich weiß nicht warum
das bei mir interessant ist und bei
anderen nicht also das wird mich nicht
interessieren warum ihr gerade meine
videos guckt das war falsch müssen hier
raus glaub ich okay müssen auf jeden
fall noch mehr farben
da erwarte ich schon mal ins kurz also
mehr lohn fahren haben wir hier das hier
ist beides millionen ich weiß gar nicht
ich glaube wir noch ein bisschen knochen
und können das ganze dann ein bisschen
hoch züchten nähe haben wir nicht auch
gut wie komplett zuckerbombe ist immer
noch machen
dafür brauchen wir bei sand vor haben
wir nur sand so weit wird
das ist jetzt unsere zucker auf waren
hier gebaut direkt abhaken
punkt so wie er da frage ich mich auch
also man sollte wirklich cool finden war
die aufgabe stand da und da gucke ich
mal ganz kurz haben wir leider ach wir
haben zwei spot ab der 1
also hält das netz ganz cool ich wusste
gleich dass wir davon so komische dinge
haben dann machen wir es mal ganz kurz
im kugelhagel und lassen die dann ein
wenig vögeln bisschen kühlen bzw
aber die perfekten 40 mal so können wir
denn machen
ich würde sagen wir machen das einfach
mal hier
dieses blöde blick übers wochenende hier
so freifläche das gut durch gut so groß
muss das ja gar nicht sein
also jetzt kommt natürlich hier wieder
die naturschützer an und meinen so hey
voll scheiße so was habe ich mit ich hab
kein lied alles was sie brauchen und
eine tür
brauche ich dann war ich denn da hab ich
schon die commerz fahren das heißt
werden jetzt auch eine kuhherde ja auch
die hab ich auch schon abgehakt hat die
schon längst abgehakt komme ich schon
darauf sei dir bist du niedlich eine
baby co okay gut fertig schöne sache
schöne sache so gefällt mir das so muss
das sein so macht das spaß
die farbe halt die schnauze kräfte einen
stonebridge oh mein gott
ach das ist okay für 1 downgrade braucht
man vier stone für 494 cobblestone und
kohle 1224 und es kamen nur zweier
ausfälle monster beim allerdings ja so
total effektiv ist vista so muss das
sein so macht das spaß und zu
jetzt habe ich was für den stone und
auch für neue pick sachsen pixis keine
ahnung wo ich komme ich sonst muss ich
ein bisschen beraten dafür benötige ich
und dann brauche ich nicht alles warten
so 1232 noch eines top picks gut und
wichtigen sachen packen wir wieder da
rein ich brauche ich noch dich nicht ich
auch nicht so habe ich rainer kuhl 2004
stone brakes verdammt wir sollten nur
ein starcraft wären 4
aber auch geschafft wir brauchen noch
zwei aufgabenfeld mir darauf kaktus farm
und finde mehr lava ok cool
jetzt möchte ich nur irgendwie kakteen
finden professionell in der aufnahme
hier gehustet so muss das sein
wir haben unten den dingen zwar bestimmt
häufig überhaupt immer hier oben her
hallo jetzt anders ein komischer blog so
ab geht's los geht's ab geht die party
sowie ihr hört meine stimme immer noch
ein bisschen kaputt von paris paris habe
ich erzählt in den letzten lost folge
was da so los war
die mit dazu gefallen hat das heißt es
muss jetzt nicht mehr machen themen habe
ich jetzt einfach mal gar keine
vorbereitet wie immer könnt ihr team in
die kommentare schreiben ich könnte mal
kurz überlegen was hat man denn ein
thema in die kommentare geschrieben
ich sollte bei dirk bach reden meinten
einige
ja was euch darüber reden ich mein
schillerstraße war genial er war ein
genialer schauspieler
der war ja jetzt gerade ein paar in
berlin und wollte daher ein neues stück
aufführen und hat sich dann extra eine
wohnung gemietet in der nähe vom theater
und ist dann halt nach dem theater
training probestunden nach hause
gefahren
seine wohnung und wird dann am nächsten
tag um 15 uhr tot aufgefunden
und zwar wahrscheinlich also der hatte
auch schon so medikamente genommen was
für welche tat waren weiß ich nicht das
hatte focus und land auch zu dem
zeitpunkt wo meine nase ist komisch dass
hatte focus online auch zu dem zeitpunkt
noch nicht so wirklich veröffentlicht
glaube ich wo ich das gelesen habe
ok jetzt eben eine höhle und dann wurde
er dort halt am nächsten tag um 15 uhr
aufgefunden weil er zu spät zur probe
stunden kam ist ein trainer einfach zu
ihm nach hause gefahren und wird dann
dort tot aufgefunden und man kann halt
sagen er war ein richtig guter
schauspieler konnte lustige rollen aber
auch ernste rollen spielen und ich finde
es einfach nur schade dass er jetzt tot
ist dass man quasi dschungelcamp
dschungel camp mochte ich jetzt nicht so
sehr aber dadurch ist jetzt auch so ein
bisschen
ich sag mal bekannt geworden du scheiße
das stimmt ganz viele mops drin oder gar
keinen akku liegt es vielleicht daran
dass ich auf baseball spieler ja das
könnte sein
entschuldigung das wusste ich gar nicht
also die welt hat auf jeden fall einen
grandiosen schauspielern grandiose
menschen verschlossen wölfe verloren
verloren aber ich möchte mir dadurch
jetzt ganz die laune vertrieben sondern
oder euch auch nicht denn das sind
eigentlich nicht so ernste themen sollte
man eigentlich nie ins play behandeln
sondern mehr so themen die halt so
billig sind die man halt so
zwischendurch behandeln kann und nicht
jetzt sogar dem tod und das leben danach
das sind mehr so themen für den und die
to get your wälder quatschen wir nur bei
sonntag zum beispiel goethe und sein
analyse verhalten oder komische fabeln
von minecraft pocket letztes zu gast war
duca schoss aber so ein ganz anderes
limit der unterhaltung
kann man echt eigentlich schon so sagen
so wir brauchen auf jeden fall noch mehr
von diesem komischen stones und ich erst
mal ein bisschen ruhe
ich habe immer noch keinen körper bei
mir hat einer in taek gesendet und hat
mir dann ein download-link gesendet und
meinte so haye kommen hatte das runter
da sind die zombies ganz und ich hab ich
wollte aber nicht machen als ich wollte
mir das nicht runter rauf ich wollte mir
das nicht runterladen
weil ich war schon mal so ein bisschen
angst wegen viren und so weit jetzt auch
beim sky virus hat man hat ja gesehen
dass man nicht allzu naiv sein soll
und naja sollte man ändern angreifen
ich glaub das ja uncool oh mein gott
jockey diesen selten oder
mein gott dabei wirklichkeit ein skelett
auf 101 skelett auf einem auf einer
spinne ist ein spyder jockey so heißt
das glaube ich
das ist halt wenn ein blauer 200 so geht
es nicht leicht ist halt wenn ein
skelett eine spinne reitet und dann
setzt reiten im sinne von einfach nur
drauf sitzen nicht dass ihr wieder denkt
hier
und dann schießt die spindel quasi sage
ich mal
also nicht die spinne schießt sondern
das skelett schießt und die spinne
reitet
das ist weil sie das gefährt von diesem
von diesem skelett ich glaube so kann
man dort ganz gut erklären
jedenfalls brauche ich noch mehr also da
war die platte gerade ganz kurz
zurückgespult ob man mit welt auf in
dieser folge ich schon so viele sachen
das intro packen könnten aber das mit
dem spyder jockey dann hat darauf eine
kuh farben war egal müssen einfach sehen
was etwas vom intro war
ich denke es war dass beide jockey ich
habe keine ahnung was ganz neues das ich
keine ahnung hat
soll seine schöne treppe einstein harry
potter und einstein wissen wo mein gott
ich bin kurz vorm sterben fed mit drauf
habe ich noch brote ich kann über die
fische essen lecker fische so die
stolberg samba die sonne zur kraft
müssen wir gegen zu hinsetzen
das kann ich ganz kurz machen und ich
schlafe glaube ich mal ganz kurz und
zwar ganz einfach weil ich keine lust
habe ja ich war vorher noch im gaylord 1
aber dass es nicht weil ich wiederum
geflogen bin da meint nämlich leute an
was im game auf weil du hier oben
geflogen bist und so deswegen da sieht
man doch dass du dich in gamer draus
gemacht hast